good morning Hank it's Tuesday I thought
today I would answer all the questions
that you asked Charlie McDonnell in your
last video thereby briefly fulfilling my
dream of becoming Charlie MacDonald also
it gives me an opportunity to tell you a
story about astronauts parting on the
moon but I have to run a lot of errands
today so walk with me how are you doing
I'm doing okay I'm excited to see the
new office but first I got to go to the
old office how is Missoula I love
Missoula it's the only town in Montana I
ever visit so it always reminds me of
that great Richard Hugo poem degrees of
grey in Phillipsburg of course begins
you may come here some Sunday on a whim
say your life broke down the last good
kiss you had was years ago so Hank this
is the lazy boy mom got me for my 23rd
birthday where I've written all of my
novels and this is the old office I love
the old office because it has my chair
and I can place would we poopers videos
here but it is also quite small and I
share it with Stan and sometimes Danica
and occasionally Tim admittedly none of
them is currently here but I swear they
are not imaginary friends what was the
last thing you screamed at probably the
most recent time was last night I had to
take some recycling out into the garage
and it was dark and I got creeped out so
I just did a pre-emptive scream in case
there was an intruder hiding in the
garage a big fan of the pre-emptive
scream I think it's underrated that's my
new office look at my view of the river
god I love rivers if you could eliminate
one word from the English language what
would it be celebrity you could go back
in time and kill baby Hitler would you
kill baby Hitler Hank I can't believe
you're still asking this question five
years after the advent of the evil baby
orphanage no I would not kill evil baby
Hill or I would kidnap him okay now I
have to go get my movie deal notarized
today is the day of the best Aaron's
ever what was your worst challenge um
all the eating ones were pretty bad but
definitely waxing my chin was the worst
if you had to get a tattoo what would it
be I think I'm too old to get a first
tattoo but I like the idea of getting a
brown dot tattooed on my shoulder and
then people would be like I really like
your mole because you know that's
something people say and I'd be like
it's not a mole it's a tattoo and
suddenly there is a storm do you spend
more time writing or editing your videos
writing but more importantly I want you
to ask yourself what is the thing you
most don't want to step on when leaving
your car bloody glove back home are you
an unusually gassy person I think I'm
regular gassy but hey did you know that
the astronaut John Young once got the
farts on the moon he
was on the moon and he was like man I
got the farts again I got crazy fracking
farts only he didn't say frakkin instead
he dropped the first f-bomb on the moon
and then gave one of the greatest
moments in moon history NASA came on the
line and they're like mm-hmm
commander young you've got a live mic
there and then there's this wonderful
pause in the recording and then John
Young comes back on and says uh how long
has the mic been on you spend more time
making videos or playing video games
that's easy I spend way more time making
videos in fact the only time I ever
played video games is when I'm playing
as the Swingtown swooty poopers wait his
Angry Birds a video game because that
would change my answer do you want to go
play video games now
yes I'm preparing for season four where
the Swindon Town Sulu poopers will go
for their third straight two FA Cup and
don't tell me it's a made-up thing Hank
if it's a made-up thing why do I have a
real trophy don't tell me it's a plate
it's not a plate it's a trophy Hank
please say hi to Charlie for me I will
see you on Friday
PS nerdfighters what are we doing for
Hank oh damn I'll hopefully you'll do
lots of fun nerd fight astok things
Ranko 2-mile I have a present for Hank
that involves you that I will reveal on
Hank Oh de Mayo